You said you were a fairy, but
Mr. IV, you
've been helping me for a long time
.
Those who call them fire spirits are those who make a contract with them and borrow their strength
When I can't, they'll be my strength
But that kind of thing can be dangerous
Cute Emilia Nuoooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooo cute, to
me
, I'm going to be a sorcerer I'm going to be a sorcerer more seriously
How are you going to take responsibility?
I'm in trouble, is
n't it?
Even Orotoro-sama is like a little child.It's okay, so it's too much
to say anything after the king.Do you know how old I am now?
I've grown too beautiful to be called a young child, but I
'll forgive you for the wand.
I'm sorry